login come to this video and playing
Mora Mora from the Netherlands do 40 45
he was an unusual move against king porn
openings and let's see let's see the
room Italian game or Scotch the Scotch
is pretty popular in the Netherlands
okay still the Royal okay go 86 now d 6
just trying this Steinitz deferred again
just want to have some variety in them
in the openings my normal move being
Knight f6 and down and visually 7 coming
next yeah here white Manor moves our
castles and c3
one difference is that after c3 black
ass the move f5 and a funny line so
called SI esta variation yes and castles
yeah yeah I know Bishop g-force one move
but I can probably just just play em
like this right I'm really making up
things here as I go along if he goes d4
I probably still have this be 595 m but
maybe still an idea deform hmm d 4 p-5
Bishop e3 94 94 84 c 3 might be a
problem okay it's not doing that yeah
it's gone i have 6 attack this one idea
of blacks line years that i have not yet
played Bishop e7 so I think g6 is a
possible setup now on d4 I go b5 and
Bishop g7 just being quick enough with
castling so that f7 is protected and now
be 5 i'm not one hundred percent sure
but i think i have seen this in at least
one game of even sokoloff Sokolov being
one of them guys to watch if you want
ideas for your iphone 5 repertoires
black he is just very creative and have
finds new anthem well forgotten lines
all the time for black yeah this looks
like pretty normal ruler past position
just
with a quick fianchetto hmm ok and
behave form yeah probably i should just
castle right if I castle there is no
tactic am like taking ruka 8 Queen ad5
exposing the seven Bishop for example
it's not a big point no i think i can
just castle in fact i think i had this
on the board in am and a correspondence
style game on chess calm remarkable if
it's not the same position that's very a
very close to it Bishop g5 could be a an
idea trying to renew this threat of a b5
rokade the problem after a be a beer ok
ed nate is that the Queen on d1 is
somewhat looking at the d7 bishop with
the caption if I ok this did not happen
he just played 92 um yes can I go rook
e8 now I really want to yeah 95 I have
rookies 7 yeah yeah I was hesitating for
a moment but yes he's going for that
interesting rookie 7 there is no I can
always cover it with the eight it should
be aight i was thinking of bishop f7
look at seven queen bee three of these
kind of ideas but there are multiple
ways to combat that even bishop yay to
serve as a move and this not g5 it it
only really helps white if you had a
move like f4 but simply not existing
a form i can just take it especially i
can take d4 Knight f3 I probably like
like D f3f I have aged six yeah
controlling the g5 square I'm not sure
that Nyjah fibers really am anything
okay here I didn't have any choice and
still I always have Bishop e8 like
Bishop f7 Luke f7 queen bee three Bishop
I'd shouldn't be any big problem yeah
that this this pretty much commits them
to sacrifice doesn't that after h6 I
don't really understand it to be honest
takes takes Knight age form no not
really okay show me what you got young
and thought just d5 and there is no big
point there I mean what quite cannot
really return maybe you can do that I
mean Bishop h3g a tree sooo badly but
maybe it stops like a total disaster the
only move making any sense is really a
sacrifice let's say a capture it's not a
big material sacrifice on f 79 f 7 or
Bishop of 79 f 7 ER okay rook takes I
must do that
and what's the point now I really don't
see it you can give the check greenbee
Jerry check here check yeah maybe our
what because he gets be five okay okay
maybe you can do that mmm we should be
six Queen takes d5 the Sun is hanging
that's a direct direct problem
now why just get into ponds that's not
too shabby I wonder if I can play can i
play it with some sort of discovered
discovered move 95 the Queen takes
Knight deform but there's always a check
here King evade queen bee 594 Quincy
five check that's really not good um
okay let's do it differently this is
what i was seeing as the first line
between b5 and now I saw 98 98 26
attacking the Queen and getting the
night over there covering E five it's
not okay i can also play 97 hmm to cover
that not quite sure it would be nice
though to get rid of this queen with 98
2d 697 I'm not so sure where it is going
ok I'm I'm doing that the night on d6 is
also attacking the whole pond admittedly
the knight on f6 is attacking it as well
but if I've was just hanging that didn't
really see how to protect it
now that's a tense game I really didn't
understand this concept but ok is
getting too he's getting two pawns and
two pawns and the rook against the two
minor pieces is not bad at least at some
from a purely material point of view ok
still not so easy frame to find the good
roles for species the bishop on c1 yeah
there is not really much hurry up it
should be 396 even close to winning the
e4 pawn yeah well the bishop on c1 and
the rook only one they don't do much my
king is safe that's good and 926 it
would square the night there on d6 is
protected by the pawn it takes e4 and
potentially can go to see from so pretty
good piece placement yeah well 96,000
was the plan anyway
the move i mostly expect a while Quincy
five I can't a key for with the tempo
yeah and I cannot only do that I will do
that quindi three then covering E form
or where is he going hmm yeah queen d
three I don't know there are some ideas
Queen a force a move that I instantly
like it activates the Queen and a checks
in for directly unite see Fort Campbell
doing interesting very interesting you
fall slightly vulnerable move like
Bishop c4 I can do to see too well it's
not really help okay let's let's
activate
92 maybe yeah that's probably a good
move tough to play his pawn structure is
a very young very young um very
harmonious no weaknesses can even play
have three to bolster this pawn now i
wonder if i should play Knight a5 Nazi
form but the moment it arrives on c4
there is so be three queen hm maybe
attacking the bigger pond okay maybe
this would have been a good choice
immediately
one idea that i have is on quincy too if
you should decide to cover be to that
where there's not a five to see for what
i want to do is I want to use the pieces
to attack and possibly freeze the
opponent's pawns like night a 5c form
attacking me too this would be a good
general idea or maybe very long term
likessee 5c form yeah blocking or fixing
the pollen be too so that I can attack
it later this is very tricky to to
accomplish though the sea pond yeah the
knight on c6 is not a particularly well
plays peace that only looks at d 4 + B
form yeah and those squares obviously
very securely covered very positive is
that I have a very safe position here
the pieces are mostly nicely protected
the king is safe and there is no
invasion I root for the rook yeah let's
say rook a 187 or something as or
cupboard and the Knights to cover lots
of squares in defense it's not clear cut
at all what white um should play him
maybe you move like queen bee one it's
not bad Queen trade um stop bad for
white Wow welcome to the age of computer
chess who's playing Bishop to b6 Wow
yeah I need a job drink something after
that move um and when I said welcome to
the age of computer chess I'm not saying
he's using a computer i'm just saying
that this is a very unhappy six okay if
I take be to like he also has rupee one
on that 20 can take c7 of all but isn't
them wow what a move night see form yeah
maybe he just um takes his 70
Bishop c4 night see form Gallaudet DNT
will take c7 very interesting
that's very difficult to to cover the
poem
very very remarkable 94 94 Bishop c4 the
screen d7 and I'm totally toast okay so
let's say on the other hand consider
what happens if i take it takes Queen
takes d6 now c6 is hanging
now so not easy to find you will move
after that as c6 hanging in Quincy's
haven't check as a threat so taking v6s
problem not helping on the other hand on
the other hand if I am just covering c7
nite nite aid I'm going to just winning
be too then you can maybe take on 670
takes Knight takes Queen d6 but then I
take and take me two words also not so
bad ok let's let's do that that's really
not a passive move read a text b6 now
for real and b2 keeps keeps and of
skipping M is kept under fire yeah
Bishop until then I will take be tuned
no look be one my queen is strapped
hmm
hmm really mm-hmm take sir could be one
Queen a to a celeb Queenie to its not
trapped but then he's got rugby seven
but this is thread ready I don't see it
you can go to be seven but i have
created or something this is all covered
Queen a three check but I've can go to
g8 okay all this didn't happen yeah
should I go just go back queen bee eight
to see a 37 I've gained a pawn that's
good but still it's not a fantastic
coordination Queen have three just to g8
are no problem there it's a good thing
that the night only two is doing so day
long
Queen a six yeah maybe just retreated to
itself not to work Queen a six no is
doing something different entirely Queen
Queen to d8 a.m. maybe into to get b5
you will go to you three anyway okay
yeah but still it's active why not let's
go here and play let's say Bishop e3
Queen d3 attacking c3 as the 3 33 the 33
porn again the c3 pawn
okay yeah he needs to get some active
play really badly f4 I know how I
thought I was probably probably not
really great but he's using quite quite
some time and not stop doing much in
terms of active come to blame ya
attacking somewhere maybe night age for
coming I take you for this Bishop age 60
that's a really bad news okay and don't
see three this Roxy one okay
yeah can't really takes you three a
look-see one is just too much the night
may be back to the six if he goes to hy
play g5 yeah yeah that's not bad all
night h 497 is also possible yeah that's
probably the best young to go 37 not
making any a direct weaknesses yeah and
the whole thing will be influenced by
time great this I didn't see fantastic
ya no lo g fiber threatened fantastic ok
my g5 maybe go here i am to cover a 6-9
g5 king here taser guy just blundered
age 60 Bishop age 6 there was of this
denied g5 winning check
gallant ESO regained a pawn no Queen
each seven
still not clear to me early I this night
only six is always attacking me for I'd
blocking the palm and c3 is still we go
in is this so terrible what not so clear
to me at the mode okay it's got Queen
Queen here
queen d 7 is a big problem
wow I don't really see a defense to that
98 and night f7 there's always nighty
six coming I can go here okay maybe a
must do that check HERE night d night
six to have seven pool
Queen c6 may be getting I can then then
you can take and plain 96 grade
what exactly is the threat i take c 3 oh
come on let's grab this i already have
you no no this this was a threat okay
check first i don't i don't know maybe
this is immediately time morning maybe I
get a night f-for no just checking on
age 6 check
if this chick on f4 Queen h6 King GA to
this check on f4 check
check
should be a draw at least check I don't
think I can win Queen age adis the
chance too much check check Jane drown
yeah I must do that you just see played
a good game what can you do now maybe
yeah around here I'm it's more like me
being in trouble around here 93 rook to
e3 was strong our very complicated game
all kinds of stuff as possible yeah this
whole way of playing is really a bit
weird but maybe it's not so bad 95 ice
may be better yeah but I wasn't if I
look at this let meet me check here
computer wants to do this why ok I see I
didn't really consider that because now
White has a very safe retreat but Bishop
c6 is of course stronger get the e4 pawn
I just win this pawn anyway okay this is
interesting okay took here and now we
had this weird we had transformation
chain of strange yeah the TF it's very
very tough 98 was my move 97 is also
possible and that I liked it but it's
not working nah yeah the computer mmhmm
yeah the engine here stockfish points
out Bishop h6 my twins
this is the idea check mmhmm yeah
computer chess 98 is not working I need
to go to d7 but maybe equal play on
something amazing yeah this was possible
the should be age six no everything's
okay again yeah maybe I should have gone
to aid to immediately yeah this is
totally we had moved there should be six
yeah my reaction was probably not bad
and now I can just take me to so he
basically has given a pawn for for that
month not much and around here I must I
must try to improve this hunting the sea
porn is a bad idea I should just play
Knight f6 why didn't I do that I mean
this is this was my original idea
getting this into play maybe getting
night h5 prepared g5 or something so
does this is just okay I mean okay a
black is better yeah I'm quite
substantially better hmm now and this so
yeah I'm know I'm blundering to this
here yes so on it not before but he did
yeah this is just just a bad bit
position I would seem tonight H fries
flat-out win very nice check this is one
problem well so light ash hole would
have won the game yet here I'm under
under some substantial pressure but
maybe I'm not lost the computer wants to
take on c3 also with a big edge the app
like a sir he's not in good shape I was
trying to hold on
Queen t6 now yeah this is probably
already a varied Rorschach this is a
draw check check yeah this was some very
tough funny most of the gamer was worse
and could have easily lost bishop age 6
of course a very very nice very nice
strike in this position instead of this
Bishop takes very nice ok thanks for
watching